[Musique]
il y aura bientôt 10 ans alexandre
soljenitsyne était expulsé du rss avec
sa famille après un séjour à zurich
il a finalement choisi de vivre dans la
solitude de l'état du vermont au nord
est des états unis dans une région
autrefois occupé par les français voici
le village de cavendish ou ses enfants
vont à l'école lui aussi habite une
maison de bois que pour des motifs
évidents de sécurité nous n'avons pas
filmer pour le reste les caméras
d'antenne 2 on le verra on tue toute
liberté
on voit bien ce qui a séduit l'écrivain
dans cette région de montagne au climat
rude les arbres les forêts d'érable de
boulot et de sapins qui lui rappelle les
forêts de sa russie natale la propriété
des sceaux génétine est très à l'écart
du village dans les bois pas de fils de
fer barbelés comme on l'a raconté les un
banal grillage l'été quand il fait beau
il va écrire dans une sorte de datchas
au bord d'un étang vont travailler en
toute quiétude à larrau rouge sa
monumentale histoire de la révolution
soviétique se gênent et zina choisi
l'exil dans l'exil en ce week-end de la
toussaint c'est un superbe exil
ensoleillée aux couleurs vertes jaunes
et rousses du vermont tu
quand nous sommes arrivés toute la
famille soljenitsyne nous attendait
dehors
voici catherine fait le bas c'est la
belle-mère de soljenitsyne ligne at 11
ans le second fils alexandre soja lysine
chauve en barbe légendaire hier mollet
13 ans et les néo natale il épouse qui
était mathématicienne en urss et enfin
stéphane dix ans le troisième fils
manqué dimitri fils d'un premier mariage
de nathalie à boston pour ses études
alexandre soljenitsyne aura 65 ans le 11
décembre
il est en pleine forme entre deux
longues séances d'écriture
il aime bien se dégourdir les bras au
vrai il n'aime pas rester à ne rien
faire il est toujours en mouvement en
passant sans transition d'un cours de
mathématiques ou d'astronomie à ses
enfants à un exercice de bûcheron
je servais
il a accepté avec beaucoup de simplicité
et de gentillesse d'être filmé mais pas
question de lui faire tourner de nouveau
une scène écrivain et père de famille da
comédien y est
le soleil du matin tombe en abondance
sur une toute petite chapelle simple
accueillante aux murs tapissés d'icônes
elle est attenante aux salles de travail
de l'écrivain
une des grandes joies des sols génie
jean c'est lorsqu'un prêtre orthodoxe de
leurs amis vient me dire la messe
[Musique]
pouvait l'imaginer en arrivant à
cavendish
je verrai l'auteur de l'archipel du
goulag prix nobel de littérature en
short avec une raquette de tennis dans
les magasins d'un dispositif caudal se
court de tennis
ce gène eysines l'a fait construire dans
sa propriété le sol recouvert d'un fin
gravier trop mou sur lequel les balles
rebondissent mal peu importe ce sont les
gestes du tennis qui séduit ce génie
jean et la liberté d'y jouer plus que la
compétition il n'a pas l'intention de
s'inscrire à flushing meadow quant à
hyères melet comme ses frères
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils ne préfèrent
pas au tennis le football américain où
le soccer
michelin fait rêver de jouer aussi nommé
n'y a ni cadavre sur julie ni à blâmer
toute ma vie s'est déroulé tétras entier
et jamais inquiétées
non je n'ai jamais eu d'argent pour
acheter une raquette a pas tant que ça
puisque fois une exposition soviétique
il est très difficile d'avoir accès aux
cours de tennis n'ont pas tomber à la
prison
les icaunais bilingue jamais je n'ai pu
jouer au tennis
il est arrivé voilà j'ai pu me faire un
cours de ces sept ans j'ai réussi à
jouer ça me donne vraiment un sentiment
de bien-être
c'est pas du sport à côté de la maison
familiale
ce génie jean s'est fait construire
spécialement pour son travail une maison
de deux étages en briques et en bois ici
une grande salle bibliothèque où il a
réuni son énorme documentation au dessus
le bureau où il écrit et dans lequel
sera enregistré l'entretien
nathalie est plus que l'épousé avec sans
se gêner zine son unique collaboratrice
elle note classe tape répond conseil
chez les sujets ni jean pas de
secrétaire pas même une employée de
maison
non seulement nathalie s'occupe de
l'éducation de ses enfants
mais c'est encore el aidé de sa mère qui
fait le ménage et la cuisine
quant aux méthodes de travail de
l'écrivain elles sont méticuleuse et
rigoureuse excusez-moi alexandre ce
jezzine mais je suis stupéfait par
toutes ces fiches qui couvre toutes vos
tables à quoi sert-elle matériaux et
techniques carthage où je veux juste le
niveau du péloïde est encore au montage
ou quatre pattes on community mais
qu'attend le milieu de journée et au
micro d' un malinké courson qui estime
aline qui pousse ce qui ferait de ce
voyou gestion ce tissu minya tasse
estime 10/14 construite rahmane
et taxes grenade rosbif serge toubiana
jaune à la sbee camions qui me couche
rouge pour votre officier aux côtés d'
appât ton saïdi nick young en vaut pas
combien pénétration tout va
notre nouveau système est et quel est le
quel est le rôle de madame sorgini
tunisia tunisia puis ça je trouve ça va
aller ces machines inscrites chez
norauto et la modifier
votre excellent aubry l'aîné hier me
l'ait tap les textes de son père sur une
imprimante qui donne des pages analogue
à celle d'un livre et sur lesquels
soljenitsyne portera plus tard ces
corrections stéphane le plus jeune lui
aussi est de son père si tu fais et
stéphane
[Musique]
je
il n'y at on en joue le deuxième
concerto de better il vient de faire ses
débuts de concertiste dans leurs caisses
professionnels de l'état du vermont
e
mais
et
[Musique]
alexandre soljenitsyne je voudrais
d'abord vous remercier de m'avoir
accordé le privilège ainsi qu'à toute
l'équipe d'antenne 2 qui m'a accompagné
ici de privilège de passer une journée
avec vous dans votre famille
et puis ce privilège de l'entretien que
nous allons avoir dans votre bureau à la
table même où vous écrivez tout vos
heures la raison de cet entretien c'est
la publication à paris aux éditions imca
presse en langue russe de la version
définitive et complète doute 14
de même les éditions fayard viennent de
publier en france cette version
définitive et complète c'est-à-dire 400
pages de plus que la précédente version
de 12 14 et je signale ses 400 pages et
ils ont été traduites du russe par
geneviève et je sais jouer mais quand je
remarque une chose sur ce gros livre
c'est que y'a marqué certes ou 2,14
milliards marqué la roue rouge
et puis premier ne qu'est ce que la roue
rouge
qu'est ce qu'un premier ne craint ce
n'est qu'en laissant leur rouge et le
récit de leur révolution russe
c'est vrai si à la différence des
romanov le récit est taxée non sur deux
ou trois personnages non sur ont deux ou
trois lieux géographiques
le récit en grâce des centaines de
personnages pour la plupart réel
historique
il embrasse également des dizaines de
lieux géographiques en russie c'est
comme le mouvement de la russie emportés
dans le tourbillon révolutionnaire
matière immense il faut prendre en
considération qu'il s'étend sur
nombreuses années obligé de commencer à
l'année 1914 le mener jusqu'en 1922
impossible de décrire sans d'action tant
de personnages sur une telle étendue de
temps pour cela j'ai choisi pour mon
récit la méthode des points nodaux ou
nude et ne c'est à dire que je choisis
des segments de temps réduit à deux ou
trois semaines
là où se passent les événements les plus
pittoresques ou bien qu'ils restent
seuls les causes les plus fondamentales
de ces événements et je détruis avec
force détails uniquement ses segments ce
sont eux qui forment les noeuds entre
les noeuds je ne décris rien et c'est en
reliant les points nodaux que je
restitue la courbe ci lieuse de ce
mouvement
quatorze constitue le premier de ces os
oui mais il y aura combien de noeux et
combien sont écrits ce coin canapé ça
n'a été le cas il a donné j'ai écrit
trois autoroutes 14 octobre pour vous
plutôt novembre 16 mars 17 la révolution
proprement je suis en train d'écrire le
4e e
il en faudrait beaucoup mais
malheureusement ma vie sans doute
s'arrêtera avant que c'est terminé
oui je voudrais quand même mener ce
travail jusqu'au 7e ministre pour
expliquer le pourquoi de la révolution
d'octobre
à partir de là tout deviendra clair mais
la roue rouge c'est aussi me semble-t-il
une métaphore saint etienne baulieu
touch 9 à l'ajax j'ai trouvé que c'était
l'expression la plus adéquate de la loi
de toutes les révolutions y compris de
votre révolution française
quand se met à tourner cette grandiose
roue cette heure ou presque cosmique
si on porte tout un peuple des peuples
entiers et ses propres agents sont
emportés comme des grains de sable qui
tourne un puissant dans ce tourbillon
est le plus souvent il y périssent est
il vrai que ce travail gigantesque de la
rouge
c'est une ambition de jeunesse et que
vous en aviez d'ailleurs commencé la
rédaction avant la guerre vous étiez le
premier déclic je les ressentis
elle me disant en dessous d'ici qu'il
est entre deux candidats n'a pas changé
lui guerre et paix de tolstoï ce pour
quoi il s'agit je sentis aussitôt une
aspiration écrire une oeuvre importante
la même année aussi j'ai lu édité en
urss malgré la censure les souvenirs de
shulgin un membre de la douma écrit pas
du tout en faveur des bolcheviks un
récit très émotionnel j'ai été séduit
par ce livre mais sans doute parce que
j'étais trop jeune ces deux impressions
ne seront pas recrutés et à cette époque
là le dessin ne s'est pas formée en
disent ont passé depuis
j'ai terminé l'école soviétique à 18 ans
et je me souviens très bien de la
journée en novembre 1936 quand
subitement ce dessin m'a saisi ça s'est
passé il ya cinquante ans de cela j'ai
décidé alors d'écrire une grande épopée
sur la révolution russe avait
entre-temps l'éducation soviétique a
fait dévier mon esprit et j'ai cru que
ma tâche principale serait de décrire le
coup d'état d'octobre
je croyais que c'était là la racine des
événements à tonga ce temps je suis donc
parti en arrière pour ne pas commencer
par le coup d'état d'octobre il fallait
commencer avant mon crédit 917 montrer
la guerre de 1914 il ya de cela quelques
années j'ai compris que je ne t'ai pas
encore assez près pour décrire la
révolution monde peut comprendre la
révolution uniquement partir de la
gueule il faut présenter aux lecteurs le
mouvement des idées et des événements
révolutionnaires la montée de la terreur
révolutionnaire sur une plus grande
étendue de temps je suis donc revenu en
arrière
de 1914 divers 1911 vers l'assassinât de
staline
et puis j'ai compris qu'il fallait aller
encore plus loin jusqu'en 1905 jusqu'au
début du siècle mais est-ce que vous
avez gardé par devers vous les premières
lignes de ce que vous avez donc écrit
sur route 14 avant la guerre quand vous
aviez 18 ans du diagnostic et imap
stadistes nice maternante octobre à la
vanne à nice matin à nalout au top 14
nismo telle anomalie culmine à boston et
emilie danew may cry assène y assistent
ailleurs ce sont des cahiers presque
d'écoliers alors champion la personne et
je dire ce qui me porte comme storim
voyez ramasse comme personne composition
et à castanet vide
et comme personne ne doit pas laisser
les jeunes attaquent factory smith and
he is mine ou non comme président
alors si je comprends bien le travail
que vous faites dans la rouge
c'est un travail à la fois d'historiens
et de romancier je vais à la fois
d'historiens et de romanciers match
qu'ils aient de rendre l'histoire
véritable j'ai jugé même malséant
d'introduire trop de personnages
imaginaires dans le récit la plupart de
mes personnages appartiennent à
l'histoire qu'il soit important ou pas
il faut seulement que je possède sur eux
des témoignages authentiques
les documents les plus expressives
je les donne tel quel mais à petite dose
mais pour la plupart d'entre eux je les
retravaille pour les fondre dans le
tissu romanesque j'écris des chapitres
littéraire où j'essaie de donner au
personnage le plus de relief possible et
à l'action le plus de densité
revenons-en à haut contenu doute 14
la première partie on y trouve des
personnages qui ne font pas l'histoire
ils sont pas des premiers plans qui sont
pas de premier plan dans l'histoire est
ce que tous ces gens de vous parler
ce ne serait pas des membres de votre
famille data ya dans sa mort naturelle
tout au début je décris un peu les
membres de ma famille mon père ma mère
ils se connaissaient pas cette époque là
un fragment de la vie de la famille de
ma mère
ils jouent pas un rôle essentiel dans le
récit qui suit il s'agit d'une dernière
image la russie avant la guerre une vie
plutôt exotique méridionale il n'avait
jamais été décrites dans la littérature
russe et qui ne se reproduira plus
jamais parce que la guerre et la
révolution vont tous vallée hormis mon
père qui
un personnage important ce sont des
détails sans grande importance c'est
comme une photographie panoramique que
d'autres photographies viennent ensuite
recouvrir alors je n'oublie pas
alexandre soljenitsyne que vous avez
lutté contre les nazis
de 1941 à 1945 vous êtes entré dans
l'armée comme simple soldat vous avez
terminé comme capitaine vous avez été 2
fois décoré et je me dis en lisant je me
disais en lisant cette histoire de la
guerre de 14 je me disais qu'au fond
vous devez être très fasciné par l'
aventure à la fois humaine et une
humaine qu'est la guerre nomiya
j'attaque sauf pas été suivies didier
gadou mot est au ya des monstres aux
bannières déchets dont venez y ait
brasse touche le précieux cadeau volet
sur wii
j'avais tout va et nous passons tout
shopping list âmes tristes par choplin
passant de 4 300 sonos caire mais
taqiyya pas chose sur le père d'un gain
de 6 4 et 6e mais insuffisant cdc comme
sabrina steyr ce mont vidéo vous montrez
bien que pour les révolutionnaires de
l'époque cette guerre entre la russie et
l'allemagne ça a été une chance inouïe
et je voudrais vous lire ceci vous dit à
maman
pour les révolutionnaires de l'époque
l'important n'était pas à qui la faute
mais comment profiter au mieux de la
guerre tous coupables
sinon impossible de saper le
gouvernement du dard une vraie chance
que cette guerre
elle servirait utilement le socialisme
international elle nettoierait d'un seul
coup le mouvement ouvrier tout le fumier
accumulée sous la paix da est empoigné
les est un prénom à l'epagnol alliance
qui regroupe à sa mort naturelle
le groupe de lénine celui qui allait se
réunir à zimmerwald avait compris dès le
début qu'on pouvait utiliser cette
guerre pour renverser
le régime russe mais pour cela il
fallait faire croire que l'allemagne
n'était pas seule coupable que tous la
france angleterre était également stable
de cette guerre initialement souhaité
être l'alliée du kaiser et il a été
pendant quelques temps en russie
soviétique nous a inculqué pendant des
dizaines d'années que c'était la
bourgeoisie qui était fautif de cette
guerre et que l'allemagne n'avait pas
plus de responsabilités que les pays de
l'entente
et puis la deuxième partie d'août 14 et
c'est la partie inédite
c'est le récit très long et aussi très
minutieux de l'assassinât de stoli pin
qui était le premier ministre du dard
par révolutionnaire nommé bogrov vous
avez beaucoup d'admiration pour ce taux
lippi ne vous en faites un portrait très
flatteur vous le décrivez intelligent
fort
persévérant ferme sur ses positions et
vous avez même jusqu'à dire que stoli
pin était au fond la dernière chance
d'une serre est-ce que historiquement
c'est vrai d'abord converti n'attaque
pas m'acheter la race d'installer dira
si mon récit rétrospectif et emmène au
début du règne de nicolas de village et
du monde très bien ah non ce chapitre
adieu les dix premières années de son
règne
on avait déjà ce qui est tellement où
jésus
est-ce que la russie s'était retrouvé au
bord de l'abyme lépine a réussi à sortir
la russie de cet habit elle a placé sur
la voie d'un développement énergique 6
lépine n'avait pas été assassiné
si ce développement qui modifie la
structure sociale de l'état pas
seulement l'économie
si ce développement avait pu continuer
encore quelques années la russie
n'aurait jamais été ébranlé comme elle
l'a été
hassina de sto lépine ensuite convaincu
a décidé du sort de la russie les choux
parce que la direction du pays a échoué
à des gens faibles et peu expérimentés
oui mais à ce propos vous parler des
coups de feu qui ont abattu les deux
coups de feu qui a battu stolipinovo
lire ce passage c'est la fin du chapitre
je le dis pour les téléspectateurs
français stoli pin est abattu donc au
cours d'une soirée de gala au théâtre de
kiev alors ses coups de feu n'étaient
certes pas une nouveauté dans l'histoire
russe
mais que de promesses en eux pour tout
le xxème siècle ni à cet instant ni plus
tard le tarn des 110 9 1 voir le blessé
il ne vint pas il ne s'approche à pas et
pourtant c'était la dynastie que ces
balles avaient tué les premières balles
de yekaterinburg et je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs français que c'est à ce
dieu ekaterinbourg dans ce lieu que la
famille l'usr a été massacrée vous
pensez que sont les premières balles
contre un familier du désert et contre
lui même dareta twisto et de ses bus
mais vous faites un portrait très sévère
du tsar nicolas ii vous le montrer
faible plus il anime et ne montre aucune
reconnaissance à stowe lippini d'hyrule
euros par tête
ja atchia fia qui craignait que sa
machine pirates
personnage ya sam lui dis pas qu'on
observe au squad nice blajan ya beaucoup
john ils ont brisé obligé c'est presque
toutes ces critiques mais je les fais
avec beaucoup de précaution il n'y a
jamais un très trop pacéré jamais un
reproche trop dur on ne peut comparer
mon portrait avec celui qui avait été
fait par là toute la société radical
russe qui le traitait des derniers mots
j'ai donné tout le cours de sa vie
car tel qu'il a été vraiment c'était un
homme de grande qualité spirituelle et
d'une grande pureté
un chrétien conséquent m'étais pas fait
pour tenir le gouvernail de la russie
durant une telle tempête qu'on a viré
pas notées par les vagues
oui mais enfin alexandre soljenitsyne
quand même le hasard ne va même pas au
chevet de sto lipides lorsqu'il est
blessé et ne lui rend même pas une
visite c'est pas un homme de grand coeur
quand même s'il vient pas le voir ce
n'est pas parce qu'il n'a pas et qu ils
ne sont pas la force de briser l'
ordonnance d'une fête suivie par des
milliers de personnes
il ya un protocole il estime qu'il doit
se rendre à auve rouge à tchernigov
comment faire et que ces milliers de
gens qui l'attend il vient voir une fois
le mourant mais celui ci est sans
connaissance il ne revient pas parce
qu'il est elle est occupée par le
protocole non ce n'est pas si simple
ce n'est pas qu'il est sans coeur il ne
comprend pas l'importance de ce qui
s'est passé
il ne comprend pas ce qu'on perd en sto
lépine peut-être parce qu'il était déjà
un peu déçu par lui et puis ce qui rend
août 14 très actuel pour les lecteurs
d'aujourd'hui c'est votre description du
terrorisme et vous consacré de
nombreuses pages à bogrov qui est donc
l'assassin de stoli pin mais j'ai
l'impression que ce bogrov il ressemble
beaucoup à des terroristes d'aujourd'hui
en ce sens mais c'est ainsi qu'il
m'apparaît il est exaltée et il est
manipulé ya dans une case et tac toe da
at my kitchen actuelle les stars ghost
un talon de tourner sa steveté
historique de ces listes et part active
aux moins jeunes à pratiquer syrte et
réaliser précise d'ailleurs il ya bien
longtemps regretter la liste terroriste
j'ai dit on est aux anges et astra
charitative oui mais oui je à propos des
femmes vous faites un chapitre peut
effectivement jouer réussite et une qui
est étonnante
elle s'appelle eulalie roguennic ovale
résine elle habiterait ce livre de
dynamique dans son soutien gorge pour ce
faire sauter elle mène avec des
officiels des personnalités moi ça me
rappelle non seulement les kamikazes
japonais par la guerre mais des
terroristes aujourd'hui du moyen-orient
qui n'hésite pas à se mettre au volant
de deux camions bourrés de dynamite et
qui explose avec le camion c'est à dire
qu'ils font le sacrifice de leur vie
votre vie oui c'est évident lascaux
voyons là que la terreur révolutionnaire
en russie posséder tous les traits
caractéristiques de la terreur actuelle
d'une certaine façon la russie a
parcouru le chemin suivi aujourd'hui par
le monde est en avance de plusieurs
décennies sinon à glissière sans cette
galerie de femmes terroristes
j'ai voulu montrer toute la puissance de
terreur ses idées directrices ses
méthodes et je crois que c'est ça mon
permis de montrer gestion soit hier
c'était presque du tout dire
manipulés par une organisation
clandestine qui les envoyait à
l'assassinât et à la mort mais pas grave
précisément est un phénomène tout à fait
à part on its group groupe n'agissait
pas de façon aussi grossir que les
autres tous les autres terroristes
étaient envoyés par les organisations
clandestines pour tuer au péril de leur
vie ma grosse lune est dirigée par
personne assez l'opinion publique qu'il
dirige et ça c'est effrayant on y voit
autour de lui pour employer un terme de
physique il y a quand un champ
idéologique pour ceux qui se trouvent
dans ce champ le régime
l'état russe mérite d'être renversé
delépine est considéré comme un
personnage odieux
précisément parce qu'ils sauvent la
russie qu'ils cherchent à la guérir
personne ne dit à bagram où vas-tu et il
n'est lié à aucune organisation
clandestine
il a 24 ans et il décide qu'il va tuer
stoli ping pour détourner le cuir de
l'histoire c'est une forme de
manipulation plus complexe c'est une
manipulation idéologique le champ de
logique mais c'est encore plus effrayant
comme vous le voyez l'atmosphère
idéologique à elle seule peut créer la
terreur je suis frappé alexandre
soljenitsyne par l'extraordinaire
richesse des techniques d'écriture que
vous employez d'un oud 14 bien sûr le
récit classique à la tolstoï disons mais
aussi le monologue intérieur le passage
de la troisième à la première personne
et retour de la troisième personne
parfois dans le même paragraphe collage
titres de journaux instantané flash-back
etc etc
pourquoi ces deux
diversité dans l'écriture vous n'étiez
yannich manifestions je n'avais pas
l'intention d' inventer de formes
nouvelles
je me proposais uniquement de
transmettre le matériau de la façon la
plus efficace la plus dense
étant donné les dimensions de mon oeuvre
je me devais de diversifier les formes
du récit jeu pour éviter que le lecteur
s'ennuie j'ai beaucoup de chapitres
narratif
non mais la narration simple n'est pas
assez dans ce n'est pas assez efficace
elle peut donc fatiguée le lecteur aussi
ai-je plusieurs types de récits par
exemple les chapitres est à nora milk ou
je donne de condensé des événements et
où je me permet d'introduire un jugement
personnel
ce que je ne fais jamais dans les
chapitres narratif par les injustes les
personnages j'ai des chapitres que
j'appelle écrans de cinéma l'écran est
très nécessaire
localisé pour montrer toute petite
semaine dans ses moindres détails
si l'on utilise trop il c'est d'être
efficace
il devient peu spongieux par exemple et
revue de presse ni celles jugées moins
un rôle tout à fait particulier
permettent de décrire de façon qu'ils
seraient concentrés des événements tout
à fait secondaire est par ailleurs il
est très important de savoir comment les
contemporains exprimer comprenez les
événements de tap revenge la piste le
seul moyen de
écrire l'attitude de la société envers
les faits il m'arrive aussi de morceler
les chapitres narratif mais je ne fais
pas dans notre cas le store sont plutôt
long jean-marc set quand il faut décrire
la révolution heures par un minute par
des chapitres line très bref ixia qui se
télescopent et où l'effet produit par ce
centre shaun chapitre chasse l'autre la
beauté comme une quatrième dimension a
pas tant question lui car je vais
introduire le calendrier de la
révolution
c'est un très bref résumé sa politique
des événements entre les noeuds et leur
chemin et leur formulation cas font
comme si c'était vraiment l'horloge de
l'histoire qui sonnait c'est comme le
pendule de la révolution je ne suis pas
surpris que vous veniez de prononcer les
mots cinéma et écran car on ne peut pas
ne pas être frappé par la technique
cinématographique que vous employez à
certains moments et je pense notamment à
l'assassinât de stoli pin par beugré of
au théâtre de kiev vous raconter cette
cet assassinat exactement comme s'il y
avait cinq ou six caméras placées à des
endroits différents dans le théâtre
et chaque fois nous avons un récit un
peu différent du précédent
dix huit hématomes fo qui n'a escoto
ministre est-il il ya plus de 300
professionnels et non via premier tome à
18 en cash de jass trahissent vidic
génial génie à 10 h des éliminatoires
je totalise être quasi certain de ce
travail très rigolo c'est mon papa d
mais vous auriez aimé être un cinéaste
et metteur en scène sa vie ce film nous
n'étiez tipi le bateau au génial
attaquant valide pas tellement que je te
miles signé des abeilles à miel thibaut
munier non j'achète un rejeton président
annie routine patron du fil via mobile
rabattre aide les films est ce que vous
allez souvent au cinéma ce que vous avez
vu beaucoup de films durant votre vie
hirt nabot lotis yao jian
issia et sculpte une élève qui joue
votre serpent que deux pays remontent
comme c'est d'agir fluide télévision mal
être a dit à tout delhi kochi et sdi
chasse les critiques bien entendu
s'intéresse au fond de vos livres
mais selon vous s'intéresse-t-il assez à
la forme lecteur s'est attiré les
critiques en france aux états unis monde
entier ce métier j'ai à cause de mes
déclarations politiques
je les fais non pas par goût mais
lorsqu'on attend suez demande en russie
qu'il ne reste presque plus personne
pour dire les choses
comme elles se sont passées nos stars
espace tignes comme on avait tant à
cause de ses déclarations publiques
presque tous les critiques ne se prenne
pour un homme politique je n'ai lu que
des jugements sur les prises de
positions politiques je ne connais
pratiquement pas d'articles critiques
sur mon heure mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que votre célébrité comme rescapées et
dénonciateur du goulag comme ennemi juré
du communisme fait parfois oublier que
vous êtes avant tout et d'abord un
écrivain david rocher
j'en ai beaucoup d'amertume plus
j'avance en âge et pas plus je suis
triste d'être célèbre non pas pour mon
activité principale
mais pour mon activité secondaire orly
va consacrer un livre
voilà ça c'est un livre de critique
littéraire en france plus qu'ailleurs on
prête attention à cet aspect là de mon
honneur mais aux etats-unis non on ne
considère uniquement comme un homme
politique puisque vous êtes un écrivain
parlant de votre travail d'écrivain on
voit bien que vous êtes un passionné de
vocabulaire soit 20 passes tie and dye
les mots c'est le souffle constant de
l'écrivain russe qui miseront iridium je
travaille la langue russe
chaque juge depuis 35 ans bien sûr la
grille quand j'ai passé tout mon temps à
ce travail je ne pouvais pas faire autre
chose je ne voulais pas que
l'administration des cantons craignent
que je m'intéresse à la révolution
si je ne pouvais pas tenir un livre sur
la révolution russe entre les mains mais
un dictionnaire c'était sans danger
immense arbre est donc mis à
retravailler les dictionnaires russe en
particulier le fictionnaire de dalles et
je les fais pendant 35 ans y est je sens
de ce travail je considère que la langue
russe comme toute langue moderne se
rétrécit beaucoup bien entendu halak
hier beaucoup de nouveaux mots
techniques mais le relief la dimension
vivante dans toutes les langues modernes
se rétrécissant tharoor question n'est
finalisée autour de la langue
il ya toute une zone périphérique qui
n'est pas encore tout à fait si l'on
pouvait conserver cette couche
périphériques on pourrait enrichir la
langue et je travaille précisément dans
cette couche pour garder à la langue ce
qui peut encore être gars et je fais des
extraits enfin tous les maux je choisis
les mots qui peut encore être utilisé
dans la langue bien sûr elle plaisir da
alors cela c'est quoi ce sont des petits
carnets alors d'aep chasseresse jaune à
may hamm et ce sont les petits carnets
que votre que votre plus jeune fils
taper hier à la machine c'est le chien
après d'insertion après la chine et la
birmanie
mais c'est illisible d'approché facebook
myspace bebo est à bout pierre-louis
extract triste candidater mais ça
c'était dans le camp
tout ce beau monde a perdu un bâton
projet ya naturis paint ball et des
pervers
patrice pirouette brian shaw ce style
est à l'eau est bonne sachez juste avant
extract mais ça c'était c'était plus on
commence à chiché show festif les choix
qu'il est patent de soutien est en
extraction j'étais dans mon coin de
chaudun tennis oui oui mais pourquoi
écrivez-vous aussi petit aujourd'hui que
vous êtes libre lorsque vous étiez vous
surpris comme le pcf cette acné fils
assis châssis à 100 pc de jeu complet et
non aux jeux primés atp 14 qui plaît aux
jeunes typographie et dont je sais ce
qu'il tapait hier deux autres jeunes qui
chantait attendions des types et le glas
typographie ya mitch temps je te prends
soin gibier jeu sincère à la fin de ma
vie est ici à composer un dictionnaire
de 40 à 50 minutes et craignent pas les
mots utiles nécessaires que l'on peut
encore restitue à la langue qu'elle est
à peu près la journée de travail
d'alexandre soljenitsyne écrivain
comment ça se passe en gros noms à
washington
la journée de travail à potter va du
matin jusqu'au soir
les choses les plus essentiels j'essaie
de les faire le baht a signé le soir
tarn soir je prépare les matériaux qui
me seront nécessaires le lendemain et
donc jusqu'à acheter
on ya abouti ni parce qu'il est
habituellement je n'y arrive pas mais je
n'ai pas de date car j'écris plus vite
que je ne prépare les matériaux tard le
soir je sens que je serai pas prêt le
nom depuis que le souviens de moi j'ai
toujours travaillé depuis que j'ai formé
le projet de 7 heures
j'ai travaillé tous les jours sans
interruption
combien d'heures par jour à nice plus
tout le temps dehors du sommet des repas
du temps je m'occupe un peu d'aisance on
leur donne des leçons pratiques et
leçons d'histoire aussi d'astronomie
j'ai vu aussi des leçons d'astronomie en
même temps que coûte 14 vous fait
paraître alexandre soljenitsyne à paris
est toujours aux éditions fayard un
petit livre pamphlet intitulé no
pluraliste qui sont ces pluraliste et
qu'est ce que vous reprochez au
pluralisme votre grâce vous avez là un
bon exemple d'une activité contraintes
vie dieu sait lady n'a fait non émirats
c'est dans notre nouvelle émigration qui
compte maintenant plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes
liszt groupe 14h20 il existe un groupe
qui a trouvé le moyen congrès malgré de
quitter sa patrie lyonnais appelé à
fonctionner et qui arrivés ici se croit
autorisé à interpréter l'histoire russe
non pas seulement l'histoire actuelle
mais dans sa totalité et annie et
commune bruxelloise a pas d'eau il se
présente à l'occident comme les
commentateurs les plus objectifs les
plus autorisées qu'à 24 jan michelin qui
me zehouane j'aurais aimé ne pas
m'occuper tout cela chez fiat
il est depuis six ans depuis que je suis
aux états unis je n'ai lu aucun de leurs
écrits ils ont publié des recueils
entier de nombreux articles dans les
journaux dans les rues de manille ils
ont donné beaucoup d'interviews
ils ont fait des tournées de conférences
pendant que moi j'ai travaillé anna
rouge pendant six ans je les ai ignorer
vescemont en seconde
au printemps dernier chez lui pour la
première fois tous leurs écrits kindred
pendant tout un été pris de frayeur je
me suis dit ils sont en train de tromper
l'occident il lui donne une perspective
fossé
faux conseils ils le font sans aucun
sens des responsabilités je n'accuse pas
de mauvaise volonté mais son plein c'est
une curieuse assurances
il croit pouvoir donner de leçon à
l'occident sur son aptitude à l'égard de
la russie
leur assurance n'a pas de fondement et
n'ont pas cette connaissance vous ayez
mois n'ont pas étudié la russie pendant
deux décennies les enjeux
superficiellement
certains d'entre eux a fait savoir
saisie de l'élite soviétique
c'est à dire je suis ont participé à ses
torrents de mensonges qui se déversait
sur nous en russie soviétique
ils arrivent ici et l'on dit ici ce sont
des spécialistes des spécialistes de la
presse de la radio
les commentateurs politiques il faut
utiliser leurs compétences ainsi des
gens qui habitaient des mensonges en
russie unie pour reçoivent aussi un
grand crédit en occident il continue de
travailler
mais peut-on se fier à leur apparente
sincérité
ainsi j'ai été amené à écrire cet
article
un bref article en fait trente pages
en réponse à des centaines et de
centaines de pages qui représente leur
travail
ceci ça cette année et dans la deuxième
partie de ce petit livre vous vous en
prenez à ceux qui vouent calomnie à ce
que par exemple qui disent que vous avez
reconstruit ici un goulag
c'est complètement idiot jeu
j'en suis bien le témoin à ceux qui vous
accusent d'être un ayatollah à ceux qui
pensent que vous voulez créer un jour un
autre goulag pour aux ennemis etc
pourquoi essayer de temps de vous
calomniez comme ça qu'elle a raison est
ce que vous êtes un homme dangereux ya
bien sûr les parasites il paraît utile
store c'est d'ailleurs cet akoya mini
hilton fils les pistes at il émis
je suis les pistils sachs est ici dix
piges taille normale et de pâtisseries
pesci passage tant pis at il dit dai a
suspendu sa justiciable est libre
yasuyoshi batteries piles à hydrogène
bomag et taxes ni père d'ashley young et
b ja s'est joué là bas 2 je travaille
tranquillement on considère je suis
devenu foule et sa config est la bonne
en écrivant ne peut pas travailler qu'à
temps à leurs yeux les inattentions en
fait on reproche une vie normale
d'écrivain qu'est ce qui les pousse
apparemment il ne trouve rien de plus
substantiel à me reprocher a mis fin au
jeu les gêne parce que je suis de ceux
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps d'éliminer
minya staline n'a pas réussi à m'avoir
la poétesse armato m'a dit un jour à non
alexandrie sage nous deux
staline n'a pas eu le temps de nous
éliminer yasser voyez je suis l'un des
rares que staline n'a pas réussi à
détruire je dis la vérité sur la russie
ce qu'il en est j'ai consacré ma vie à
cela c'est pour cela que je suis un
personnage odieux
je ne leur permet pas de se présenter
comme des témoins exclusive
il faut donc me persécuter ce temps
plein regardez ils inventent des
idioties le fait que j'écrive pendant
des mois et des années signifie pour eux
que je suis un aliéné que je vis dans un
goulag et donc vous êtes un homme
dangereux à passer si je n'y croyais et
en russie jouit plus chaud à passer être
vous m'écrivent un estimé apprécié et
aimé des intellectuels américains
y at il un terrier ce cas joue bien on
ne le dirait pas non je dois dire
l'ensemble de musique et sur le monde
moderne sur l'occident est très mal
perçue par l'intelligentsia américaine
ni votre âge où nous chrétiens mon
tempérament ne leur convient pas à mon
égard la même attitude que les
pluralistes ristourne est mignonne leach
on attribue des choses tout à fait mon
songe par exemple filetées les geishas
mais risque n est pas persuadé que je
chante les louanges denis que la deux
je suis à genoux devant lui ils sont
persuadés que je préconise pour la
russie un régime théocratique nicolas
jamais personne ne me sign and whites
étape
cependant tous disent que je suis un
monarchiste un admirateur du tsar ce qui
suggère le premier pour lui je suis le
pire des monarchistes le pire des
services besoin de me poser la question
vous dites que je ne décris pas nicolas
2 du meilleur côté mais personne ne
remarque on me dit je suis vraiment à
genoux en dévotion devant nicolas ii
jamais je n'ai affirmé que le clae
j'ai devait diriger la russie pourtant
les intellectuels les plus intelligents
répètent en choeur que je prêche la
théocratie
voilà comment il n'interprète il y aura
bientôt 10 ans soljenitsyne que les
soviétiques vous en fichu à la porte de
leur pays
après quelques mois zurich vous êtes
venu vous installé aux états unis
considérez vous que vous avez fait le
bon choix
ja rule au cias mort sa dette j'ai fait
un bon choix car j'ai pu créer ici les
meilleures conditions pour mon travail
suffisamment d espace
si seulement d'excellents rapports avec
les bibliothèques américaines ou comme
nulle part ailleurs on trouve un grand
nombre de livres et d'archivés russe je
ne vais pas vivre au centre de l'orge
je pense que chaque jour j'avais jusqu'à
petits visiteurs qui chaque jour le
téléphone sonne et ont frappé à la porte
continuellement chacun voulait avoir sa
demi-heure et rien que ça demi heure ce
n'était plus une vie ni pour moi ni pour
notre famille je devais donc habiter un
endroit où il était difficile de matin
vous avez bien vu qu'il est pas si
simple d'arriver jusqu'ici grâce à cela
je peux jouir du calme dont j'ai besoin
j'ai bien choisi et toutes ces années
c'est très bien travaillé aux états unis
toutes les conditions sont réunies
hormis la patrie mais si vous trois
garçons qui sont nés tous les trois sur
la terre russe
si vous trois garçons par leurs études
par leur mode de vie devenaient de vrais
petits américains
est ce que ça vous ennuierait gagné
chemin moins jeunes au tri miyagi
avec ma femme nous prenons toutes les
mesures pour qu'il maîtrise
parfaitement le russe et nous y arrivons
ce taux bagne pour qu'ils soient
imprégnés de culture russe là aussi nous
avons réussi pour le moment nous nous
réjouissons qu'ils apprennent les
langues étrangères qu'ils assimilent une
culture étrangère mais pas aux dépends
de la culture russe grâce à d'immenses
efforts en particulier de ma femme nous
y arrivons ce sont des enfants russes
liés de coeur à la russie ils
connaissent bien et la poésie et la
peinture russe
bien sûr nous en aurions gros sur le
coeur s'il venait à nous échapper s'ils
devenaient devrait occidentaux mais oui
mais y at il un risque que vos trois
garçons perdent de l'ambition et le goût
de rentrer un jour sur la terre russe
pas qu'à sydney a terminé le bleu des
pâquerettes faire plus tard quand ce
sont des hommes des animaux j'ai emmené
à 10h des jeunes en matière d'innovation
et à s'éloigner châtellerault vienne
jeter match qui verra si heroes mais
avez-vous toujours au fond du coeur le
désir violent vous alexandre
soljenitsyne de rentrer sur la terre
russe kazakh johann hay c'est peu dire
le désir ce désir ne me quitte pas un
instant que même la certitude du retour
ne me quitte pas je ne sais d'où elle
vient
ni la situation mondiale ni celle de
l'union soviétique n'offrent aucun signe
réconfortant mais mon sentiment profond
me laisse entendre que je reviendrai
vivant chez moi dans ma patrie bien que
ce soit loin d'être jeunes comme vous le
voyez j'allais vous dirai ce que c'est
bien raisonnable d'y croire encore c'est
une conviction intime
d'abord ces chiffres bruts aux coquilles
d'huîtres est oubliée
diana catastrophe sommes son offre ce ne
pouvait supposer que je me retrouverais
un jour en prusse orientale et dans les
mêmes conditions
j'étais comme pousser vers cet épisode
une espèce de lien intime de prémonition
près de gadagne omeyer à plusieurs
reprises en effet dans ma vie j'ai
pressenti d'effets physiques qui me sont
ensuite arrivés je ne suis pas seul dans
ce cas tout homme qui n'étouffe pas son
intuition qui lui fait confiance voit se
réaliser dans sa vie non car je dirais
ses sous et non pas ses prévisions mais
ses pressentiments notre organisation
est beaucoup plus fine que laisse croire
la pensée matérialiste que nous avons de
nous mêmes
vous avez déclaré un jour et je vous
cite le régime communiste ne sera pas
vaincu de l'extérieur il sera vaincu de
l'intérieur est toujours votre opinion
c'est tout à fait mon opinion et même
plus cette opinion se renforcent à
chaque décennie pas tabou store quand
nous étions encore dans les camps dans
les années 40 du 20e siècle
nous pensions que la puissante amérique
pourrait intervenir en russie nous le
parachuter des armes pour que nous
puissions nous libérer mais ensuite nous
avons compris que l'amérique l'occident
vous savez comme on dit face au péril ne
pense qu'à toi même
le mieux qu'il puisse faire c'est de se
maintenir
ils sont loin de pouvoir modifier notre
situation
vous êtes loin de là à pouvoir nous
sauver pas sa classe
tout ce que je demande maintenez vous
vous mêmes nous empresser pas de vous
mettre à genoux comme les manifestants
pacifiques
d'europe occidentale vu que l'occident
lui même reste ferme et ne prêtent pas
main forte à nos oppresseurs et c'est
pire l'occident cède ses positions il
vient en aide à nos oppresseurs leur
vend tout le matériel qu'il demande ou
acceptent de se laisser voler oui la
libération d'un russie ne viendra que de
l'intérieur
pourvu que l'occident n'aide pas nos
tyrans mais est ce que en pologne lech
walesa n'a pas échoué de l'intérieur
nyan win a échappé au niveau non pas du
tout il a connu un grand succès
simplement je ne voyais pas vous n'êtes
pas dans les mêmes dimensions du temps
précisément le mouvement de valence 1
est un de ceux qui nous montre que les
pays de l'est peuvent se libérer
eux-mêmes
ce mouvement fait bien attention il n'a
rien à voir avec le socialisme
jamais un mouvement de libération à
l'est ne sera un mouvement socialiste le
socialisme nous est odieux avant ce
mouvement peut amener la libération mais
qu'a fait l'occident le monde entier
pour aider solidarité pratiquement rien
on a plutôt voulu épargner le
gouvernement polonais aucune aide réelle
n'est venu à solidarité plus l'année
dernière le comité nobel a eu peur de
provoquer un scandale en donnant le prix
nobel à valence a cette année grâce à
dieu grâce à dieu le prix nobel lui a
été donné
non le mouvement de valen ça n'a pas
subi de défaite nous assistons
aujourd'hui à la victoire spirituel des
polonais unis dans le christianisme
contre le socialisme et le communisme
je ne vois aucune des sept depuis
autre fameux discours de harvard
considérez-vous que l'occident est moins
pusillanime qu'avant it is cool que
niemeyer
on taxe willeman oui l'occident est tout
aussi faible aussi vulnérable
spirituellement plus qu'avant le tableau
général n'a pas changé tenez le
gouvernement américain vient de faire à
grenade une action raisonnable et juste
ce que kennedy aurait dû faire quand
castro cherché à prendre le pouvoir à
cuba et comment les gouvernements
ont-ils réagi par la réprobation
pourquoi agir si fermement pourquoi
brider les bandits occuper un pays qui
l'étaient déjà
quand les cubains ont occupé grenade
personne ne les a critiqués ils
pouvaient tuer qui voulaient prendre en
otage le gouverneur anglais
cela n'étonne personne cela paraissait
normal qu'ils installent une base
militaire qu'il stocke des armes ne
choque personne c'est normal mais quand
à la dernière extrémité l'amérique
envoie ses troupes pour libérer grenade
c'est le tollé général de tous les
gouvernements de tous les hommes
politiques tous deux crié que faites
vous là penser aux conséquences
laissez les bandits continuer les
sonneurs la voie libre
que faites vous du fameux droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes ils ont
été dépossédés de ce droit bien avant si
le gouverneur a été arrêté si le premier
ministre était tué peut-on dire que le
peuple de grenade disposer de lui-même
il a été privé de ce droit depuis
quelques années tout le monde en était
content au nicaragua pendant la guerre
civile mais c'était clair c'était si
clair mais vraiment comme l'eau de roche
que les communistes allaient prendre le
pouvoir
carter et les autres ne faisait qu aider
les communistes personne n'exige et que
le nicaragua et le droit de disposer de
lui même
maintenant que les états unis ont tendu
une main secourable au peuple de grenade
pour qu'ils puissent décider de son sort
tout se met à crier
n'y touchez pas ni toucher paco cuba
finissent d'asservir lis tu vois là
aucune contradiction au contraire
contraire
l'occident s'est teinte cinq dernières
années ne laisse pas les peuples décider
de leur sort
mais les livres toujours aux communistes
est-ce qu'on a permis au vietnam du sud
de disposer de lui-même non l'occident
et qui suggère ont trahi le vietnam tous
de s'écrier comme ses biens et le new
york times publie deux grandes photos
d'un vietnamien tranquille et satisfait
enfin c'est la paix on les a bâillonné
ils sont obligés de s'échapper par la
mer au risque de couler ou d'être mangés
par les requins et c'est bien tout le
monde est content que pensez vous de
cette idée que dieu est toujours avec
les gros bataillons iata quoi idier et
cette idée je ne la connais deux kills
façon mais d'où vient-elle cette idée on
dit en france on est toujours
qu'effectivement dieu est toujours du
côté de l'armée la plus forte parce que
là bas est la plus forte écrase la plus
faible
donc dieu du côté des vainqueurs et
c'est une sorte de proverbe français
dieu est toujours du côté des gros
bataillons leach mais au petit mon
expérience personnelle ni mes
observations sur l'histoire ne le
confirme grande de l'histoire est bien
plus complexe que ce que notre raison
peut en comprendre
mongeau pastiche galloway quand nous
croyons que l'histoire suit un cours
désespéré nous ne faisons que passer par
des épreuves qui peuvent nous grandir
ja je dois avouer que pendant de longues
années j'ai beaucoup souffert à l'idée
que la russie avait une destinée aussi
malheureuse pourquoi la russie s'est
elle trouvée aux mains de bandits qui
font d'elle ce qu'il veut puis les
années ont passé et je vois que le monde
entier refait le même chemin alors j'ai
compris que ce sont ses portes et 3 tu
par lesquelles nous devons tous passés
par choix la russie est passée la
première mais tous nous aurons à nous
glisser par cette porte étroite est
terrible
cela ne veut pas dire que dieu nous est
abandonnée a donné la liberté de choisir
et si l'humanité une génération après
l'autre une nation après l'autre un
gouvernement après l'autre accumule des
erreurs ce n'est pas dieu qui fait des
erreurs avec nous c'est nous qui les
faisons nous ne voyons pas le but de
l'humanité là où il se trouve vraiment
chez les hommes que ce soit les
individus ou la conscience historique
d'une nation d'une société prennent
souvent le confort matériel comme but de
notre existence mais ce n'est pas le but
de notre existence
au contraire cette terrible xxème siècle
peut nous ouvrir la voie d'une grande
élévation spirituelle
alors que le 19e siècle sortant si
confortable n'a fait que préparer tout
le déclin de l'humanité jusqu'en 1914 et
en 1914 qu'a éclaté la catastrophe qui
dure encore aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas comment vous le voyez en
france mais je considère qu'après la
guerre de 1914 l'europe toute entière ne
s'est jamais relevé elle n'a pas
retrouvé sa situation d'avant si
profonde était la cicatrice la première
guerre mondiale
est-ce que vous ne parlez beaucoup de
dieu
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
peut-être même physique d'écrire sous le
regard de dieu ya domota je pense que ce
sentiment est accessible à tout homme à
condition qu'ils ne se laisse pas
entraîner par l'agitation de la vie à
zama tête sous l'eau
car je viens de si loin
aujourd'hui la physique physique acquis
de toutes les sciences et la plume
matérialiste et joie quant aux frappes à
la cloison qui nous séparent de l'autre
non physique annick tony wood
ce sont les plus grands physiciens qui
ont tiré les conclusions les plus
idéalistes lynchage une autre vie ne se
réduit pas au fonctionnement de notre
organisme invisiblement avec la marche
du temps nous recevons un soutien
spirituel
chacun d'entre nous le reçoit et chaque
jour je vais tenir mme celui qui est
sensible perçoit ce soutien et chacun
peut le percevoir car nous subissons
tous de ce soutien ou cire la radio sky
est au début d'août 14 vous raconter la
visite d'un jeune homme qui s'appelle
sagna et qui ad'ailleurs l'âge de bogrov
23 ans sa visite à un écrivain est très
célèbre de l'époque tolstoï
alors voici ce que vous dites le tolstoï
se promènent et puis sagna bien que
timide laborde et lui dit léon
nikolaevitch je sais je trouve le vos
pensées votre promenade
excusez moi mais je suis
venus de si loin jonathan de vous que
quelques mots dites moi si j'ai bien
compris quelle est la fin de l'existence
humaine sur terre alors tolstoï lui
répond servir le bien et ce faisant
contribuer à l'établissement du royaume
de dieu sur la terre
oui je comprends bien dit sagna en proie
à l'émotion mais dites-moi servir le
bien
comment par l'amour précisément l'amour
et tolstoï répond sans doute uniquement
par l'amour quel est votre avis
là-dessus
d'abord je dois vous dire que mon père
après ses études secondaires
ça fait effectivement cette visite
tolstoï je n'ai pas inventé mais je n'ai
jamais vu mon père je ne sais pas de
quoi ils ont parlé avec tolstoï
bien sûr je reconstitue cette
conversation je la met dans la bouche de
mon fait l'amour sauve tout est un point
de vue chrétien absolument juste auquel
tolstoï s'accordent mon objection est la
suivante je pouvais être le siècle
nous sommes tombés bas nous nous sommes
enfoncés dans de tels abîmes que posé
comme exigence l'amour qui sauve tout
c'est comme si l'on voulait sauter d'un
coup très haut sans précédent
je considère que c'est pratiquement
impossible
je pense qu'il faut offrir des étapes
intermédiaires qu'on puisse y arriver si
vous dites à l'humanité actuelle
aimez vous les uns les autres on
n'arrivera à rien on n'arrivera pas
sauvé par l'amour il faut des appels
intermédiaire pu mesurer à 17,26 appel
pourrait être comme le dit sonia la
génie de signes dans le roman
tiab ne pas agir contre la justice de ne
pas enfreindre la justice tels que tu
l'as contre ans lubie cas n'ont pas aimé
tout le monde mais au moins ne fait pas
ce que tu ne voudrais pas qu'on te fasse
pareil pour le moins il ne fait rien qui
puisse troubler ta conscience
ça sera un premier degré vers l'amour
nous ne pouvons y arriver d'un seul coup
nous sommes tombé trop bas
donc les appels pathétiques du pape jean
paul ii pour l'amour ne servent pas à
grand chose selon vous donc pourquoi
serait-il utile
le christianisme ne peut pas renoncer à
son maximum
l'appel à l'amour du christianisme est
parfaitement juste non mais le pape se
trouve au sommet de l'échelle
hiérarchique
il exprime sa pensée comme au nom du
christ le christianisme doit continuer à
le dire mais quand on redescend vers le
quotidien vers les conversations les
décisions quotidiennes
je considère que l'appel à l'amour qui
n'est pas vraiment efficace il faut
d'abord en appeler à la justice au
respect de sa propre conscience
ne pas agir contre sa conscience voilà
c'est le premier pas à faire alexandre
soljenitsyne
ce sera ma dernière question le 11
décembre
vous aurez 65 ans que faut-il vous
souhaiter pour cet anniversaire nous
nick est au bout de nos projets au kenya
après jour est maillé goût de shingo des
chameaux bourgade aller ni si vous n'y a
pas je vais aller au speed zac winship
grace née kelly saut et cheverny
[Musique]